bonjour mairie steve à la merci de
répondre ce matin à nos questions sur rt
france trois syndicats pour donc cfdt
unsa fo ce qui représente plus de 50% de
représentativité sud et votre syndicat
la cgt contre donc est ce qu'il ya une
fracture du front syndical ont déjà je
voudrais vous dire que nous n'avons pour
l'instant pas répondu en tout cas
puisque nous sommes en train de
consulter toutes nos bases nous avons
plus de 3000 syndicats qui sont en train
de consulter dans les territoires auprès
des salariés justement pour rêver notre
réponse fait après une consultation que
nous donnerons notre réponse définitive
puisque nous n'avons pas encore répondu
en tout cas à cette question donc de
dire que pour l'instant la cgt n'a et
contre et ne signera pas nous attendons
nous la consultation parce qu'il nous
semble normal que le personnel qui
étaient mobilisés depuis plus d'un an
qu'il est qu'il est important quoi le
consulte avant de réserver une réponse
définitive
alors pourquoi appeler à une
manifestation d'ampleur mardi sans dire
finalement que vous allez pas forcément
voté contre
dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes vous
savez le personnel mobilisé depuis un an
et la date du 14 juillet a été déjà acté
avant la finalité de cette négociation
et le personnel bien sûr comme vous
l'avez évoqué en présentation de votre
sujet ne considère pas que sa folle de
toute façon de tout compte et que pour
l'instant d'un accord qui est proposé
n'est pas forcément à la hauteur en tout
cas des attentes
donc il est évident que les
professionnels continueront à se
mobiliser pour justement notamment
mettre la question des effectifs en
personnel qui n'est pas présente dans ce
protocole ou très près très peu
présentes puisque il faudrait 200 mille
emplois pour pouvoir leur répondre à aux
problèmes d'effectifs dans les
établissements mais cette hausse de 183
euros nets en deux
elle est suffisante elle n'est pas
suffisante selon vous vous parlez d'une
concertation prochaine dans vos rangs il
ya quand même un effort non 7,5
milliards d'euros ce n'est pas rien
olivier vers en vente la plus grosse
augmentation de revenus jamais proposé
en france alors la cgt qui dans les
négociations donc nous avons poussé non
justement pour que cet accord soit du
plus grand niveau possible mais
cependant il faut quand même dire que ça
fait 20 ans que les organisations
syndicales se battent justement pour des
augmentations de salaires aujourd'hui
une infirmière a une moyenne en tout cas
inférieur de 800 euros par rapport aux
autres pays européens donc vous
comprenez que malgré f qui est proposée
il ya encore de grandes marges de
manoeuvre pour nos métiers soient
réellement attractif
combien ce que vous vous demandez
exactement et comment le financer
allons-nous déjà notre organisation là
toutes les organisations dans le cadre
des mobilisations qu'il y à eu
nous avons demandé les 300 euros en tout
cas pour tout le personnel
ils font pas atteint dans ce protocole
est donc pour les financer il ya
plusieurs mécanismes déjà nous
considérons que l'investissement pour
l'hôpital est vraiment en effet faire et
qu'à ce titre là puisque le président
s'était exprimé ces dernières fêtes
d'été derniers mois pour dire qu' il
faudrait mettre les moyens nécessaires
dans ce secteur donc nous pouvons
considérer qu'il ya encore des marges de
manoeuvre possibles de justement surtout
qu'il est très important de considérer
qu'il faut augmenter les salaires
mais la grande inconnue finalement dans
ce figure et dans ce protocole c'est là
les effectifs les ratios en personnel
qui manque dans l'établissement et se
figure et ce protocole et lutte quand
même en partie la question parce que les
postes qui sont proposés sont nettement
insuffisants pour répondre à non
seulement une meilleure qualité de prise
en charge mais aussi à ce que le
personnel puisse améliorer ses
conditions de travail parce que vous
savez les personnels travaillent
énormément et en demandent justement et
de meilleures conditions de travail et
nos réductions ton travaillerait
les 35 heures ils ne vivent pas et si
cette augmentation est bel et bien
validé un je parle de celle de 183 euros
nets
d'un point de vue mensuel de 2 300 euros
dans quel esprit d état d'esprit ce que
vous serez est ce que vous serez dans un
état d'esprit jusqu'au boutiste pour
atteindre justement les 300 euros que
vous revendiquez 1
la question est ce qu'on veut dans notre
pays que l'ief que les salariés de ce
secteur et des faller qui sont dans la
moyenne européenne des autres pays et
qu'on retrouve au gros gros fédère
vraiment leur qualification fait des
métiers à prédominance féminine et qui
ne qui sont mal reconnus par rapport à
d'autres secteurs d'activité donc vous
comprenez qu'il ya une marge de
manoeuvre en important pour aller sur ce
registre est là aussi
dans ce protocole par exemple cette
volonté en tout cas n'est pas vraiment
affiché donc notre inquiétude surtout
c'est une fois que ce protocole sera mis
en place
est-ce qu'il va y avoir encore des
possibilités et des marges de manière de
discussion parce que vous l'avez entendu
ça fait 20 ans que les salaires n'ont
pas été revalorisés et l'inquiétude pour
les professionnels c'est de penser que
cette négociation et les revalorisations
en cours risque ensuite des trains faute
pour tout compter qu'il faudra attendre
nouveau plusieurs années donc forcément
les professionnels se mobiliseront
toujours encore pour essayer d'atteindre
en tout cas ce qu'il considère comme
comme des salaires attractifs puisque
nous avons beaucoup de professionnels
qui qui fuit l'hôpital public et qui
vont dans d'autres pays autour ou la
rénumération et puis est plus importante
donc c'est une question quand même qui
rêve toujours en suspens et va falloir
vraiment que le gouvernement s'attelle à
dire que au delà de ce protocole
il faut vraiment aller plus loin en tout
cas c'est la revalorisation salariale
mais surtout sur les effectifs en
personnel dans les établissements
merci merci voilà d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur ma tension arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la cgt santé et action
sociale
merci à vous